they said no smut for thee without a
government ID true you can't look at
porn till you prove when you were born
because Todd's parents are here we're
doing a story on pornography
I want to make him feel really
uncomfortable
Louisiana
's the law requiring porn sites to
legally verify their users are at least
18 years old no more just passively
clicking yes I'm 18 when prompted or
asking the public librarian for help
starting this week any commercial
website with at least 33 percent of its
content consisting of explicit material
must verify you with a government issued
ID
33 and a third percent see if there's
only a way around that
like offering 33 and a fifth percent
I thought it was a good idea but since
this is uh the Mardi Gras State instead
of an ID you can also access porn by
flashing your breasts and throwing beads
at the screen
[Applause]
users can also ID themselves with other
private documentation like education and
employment records
I mean which is a hassle for porn
Watchers I mean who are used to having
one hand free
but why
where binge drinking and flashing your
naughty bits it's part of a complete
breakfast
lawmakers says it's to prevent children
from being exposed to adult content
which of course is best left to
elementary school libraries
so now you need an ID to watch porn but
no ID to vote which is weird because in
both cases you're pulling a lever
you know uh Tyrus this is obviously
Louisiana where you're from I happen to
think that like
it sounds like it sounds impossible but
I mean we're in technology outstripped
the parents ability to control what
their kids see oh this is great I I
worry for dads who don't keep track of
their wallets though yeah you know you
don't say oh because the kids will grab
real quick and send your picture in
there yes that's the story I would go
with dads
putting that out there
[Applause]
these damn kids always getting my IDs
no oh bad idea don't do it uh
listen I I like this idea but I wish we
could go a step further Mr musk if
you're if you're watching this needs to
be on Twitter and social media as well
we need to start this would help parents
tremendously take back who's who's the
babysitter in the house we need to start
having things like this yeah it's going
to be a real inconvenience and you're
going to see a big drop yes this is
going to be a huge drop and um you know
but magazine sales might go up exactly
finally old school porn will come back
shift at the strip club will suddenly
mean something again which will lead to
jobs which will lead to more young
ladies getting opportunities for higher
education yeah this is a beautiful
beautiful thing Tyrus for speaker
speaker
but you know what this is the bitter
Part of Me David that I grew up having
to like look for porn in nearby parks
because all the perverts yeah no all the
perverts why would you go to a park
because the perverts hide the porn in
the park so you look for the perverts
you look you I would walk home from
school and you would find like a musty
Playboy in a bush next to a busty man
you know I think it was like shared porn
it was like you know how those little
things where people can leave like free
books on you know they have a little
Free Library
teenagers would like free porn in bushes
and tree holes we had a tree hole at
this park in San Mateo you go and pull
your hand out you get like a yeah we
were always told to run away from that
part of the park
what do you say I do good idea bad idea
I I don't I mean I I I I am nostalgic
also for the old days too though because
you had back then
porn titles were fun you know you had
good will humping yes
you know they were all innocent it was
fun the nutting Professor yes
we're fun times yeah now you go on
PornHub it's just like you know MILF
sloppy
[Laughter]
no crazy car where's the charm where's
the charm it's so true
you're bringing the plot back to porn
[Laughter]
is this an attack on civil liberties
everything is
um this is also it's just not going to
work because there's ways around it for
the kids
um I'm not going to share what those are
but there are ways around you're
introducing some friction they're no
they're ways and there's also ways
around it for the websites because it
doesn't apply to anything that is more
than two-thirds not porn right so let's
put other stuff on there yeah you'll
have guys walking around being able to
say like no babe I was on PornHub four
hours a day for the Articles yes
it's it turns him into the new Playboy
that is true Todd last word to you and
try to make it disgusting because your
parents mission accomplished making me
as uncovered is it too late for Joe
Machi to sub in don't you guys keep it
like a cubicle upstairs we have Joe
Mackey oh not Mochi no no he's not like
a Japanese
so sweet and doughy inside no matter how
much he wants to be sweet though inside
uh look all joking aside this thing I
must make a serious point a serious goal
of this is to unsexualize our children
exactly that is a very serious goal so
like there's no joke there keep going
with that but you know what your next
step might be I don't know toddler drag
shows after you do this yeah no but I
mean it's a fair people I mean kids are
seeing stuff that they're they're not
even ready for and then they enter times
periods were for relationships and
they're we're screwed up as it is you're
screwing them up more if you you know
anyway